hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on developing
multi-dimensional skyline spectral
libraries for rapid lipid analysis by
kaylee kirkwood haley is a graduate
student working in the baker laboratory
in the department of chemistry at north
carolina state university and i'm susie
valdez of labyrinths and i will be
moderating today's event before we begin
i want to encourage you to engage with
us
you can submit as many questions as you
want at any time during the presentation
just simply type them into the ask a
question box on the left and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the support tab
found at the top right or use the ask a
question box on the left
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter haley kirkwood kaylee you may
begin your presentation
okay good morning and thank you all so
much for tuning in today i'm kaylee
kirkwood a second year grad student in
dr aaron baker's lab at north carolina
state university
and today i'm going to be telling you
about some of the work that we've been
doing to develop multi-dimensional
spectral libraries for lipid data
analysis using the free and open source
software skyline which is out of the
cost lab at the university of washington
so here in the baker lab we collect lots
of data for lots of different types of
molecules essentially anything that is
measurable using mass spectrometry
including xenobiotics proteins
glycans lipids and other metabolites
we then use that data to understand
phenotypic outcomes for different
conditions in various environmental and
life sciences applications
and so my focus has been
really on the data analysis aspect of
this and specifically for lipidomics
data um so that we can confidently
annotate our really complex data to
gain some insight on how these lipids
are actually changing in the different
conditions that we're looking at
so to review lipids for those who may
need a little refresher lipids have many
important biological roles including
energy storage signaling
they are structural components of cell
membranes and their precursors in
hormone biosynthesis
so here i'm showing the eight lipid
categories which are defined by lipid
maps
each category has the common core
structure that's shown on the slide and
so you can see that these lipids can be
pretty structurally diverse
and then if we take a closer look at any
one of these categories we also will
have multiple lipid classes
and so here are 10 lipid classes or head
groups in this case all of which are
part of the glycerophospholipid category
and so the ones that i'll be referring
to the most in this presentation are
going to be the pes or phosphatidyl
ethanolamines
and pcs or phosphatidylcholines
and so
here we have a lipid that we would
denote pc18018
where pc is going to refer to that
phosphatidylcholine polar head group
and then 18 0 and 18 1 refer to the two
nonpolar carbon chains one of which has
18 carbons and no double bonds
and the other one has 18 carbons and one
double bond or one degree of
unsaturation
and so one of the most challenging
aspects of lipid analysis
is the complexity of the data which is
due to
lipid isomers and so here we have two
lipids from different classes one is
from pe and the other one is pc
and these have different fatty acyl
compositions different head groups but
they end up with the same m over z value
with that
and plus h
and then we can also get isomers from a
change in the fatty acyl tail
composition so here we have
the same total number of carbons and the
same total
degrees of unsaturation but the actual
tails themselves are different like this
pc 18 0 18 1 and then 16 0 21
and in most cases this is the level of
speciation that we can achieve with our
current technology and the workflow that
we're using
and then another form of isomers comes
from
the change of the fatty acyl tail
orientation which is called the sn
position
and this is where the fatty acyl tails
are the same but the connectivities are
different
and finally we can get lipid isomers
based on
changes of the double bond position so
here we have the double bond at the
ninth carbon versus the 11th carbon
so to deal with these isomers we use a
liquid chromatography ion mobility mass
spectrometry method to achieve
multi-dimensional separations and so we
use a reverse phase cc18 column to
separate the lipids by their
hydrophobicity we use ion mobility which
i'll talk about in a second and then we
use a qtof mass spectrometer in all ions
mode meaning that we collect our data
with
alternating frames of low and high
collision energy to get precursor and
fragment ions for the lipids
and so um hopefully everyone is pretty
comfortable with lcms but i'm just going
to give a brief explanation of
immobility spectrometry specif
specifically the type that we're using
in our lab for anyone who might be less
familiar with that technique
so we use an agilent 6560 which is a
drift tube iron mobility qtof instrument
the drift tube is filled with a buffer
gas such as nitrogen
and then ions pass through the drift
tube and those with the bigger size will
have more collisions with that buffer
gas and so they take longer to travel
through that drift tube
and so the output we get is going to be
drift time which is going to be
larger for bigger molecules
these drift time values can easily be
converted using what is called a single
field calibration to collision cross
sections or ccs values
which describe the surface area of the
molecule and they are molecular
descriptors so they can be compared
across labs and compared to database
values
and so here the more extended lipid is
going to have a higher drift time and
therefore a higher ccs value
and so while there are many benefits to
using ion mobility there are also
challenges and so the multi-dimensional
data that we get is very large in
complexity and file size
and manual assignment can be time
consuming and can only be done for a few
targets with small data sets
and so here we have an example of what
that complex data might look like and so
we have a base peak chromatogram which
actually looks pretty clean compared to
a lot of our lipid samples
and if we want to take a closer look at
two of the peaks here we can see the
abundance maps which show the
drift time versus m over z
with the abundance being shown as a heat
map where red is going to be on most and
most abundant and then
blue is just going to be essentially
noise and so as you can see
each one of these peaks has a lot of
features so
there's really a lot to tease out in
this data
um and we're also only looking at the
low energy or precursor scans here and
so this can get even more complex when
we start looking at those high energy
fragmentation scans as well
and so to analyze this complex
liponomics data there are currently two
main options which we like to say is
sort of like a choose your fighter match
between the manual labor and the black
box
so the black box takes your data
compares it to database information
and gives you a list of lipids usually
with some sort of rank or confidence
score associated with each
identification
so the strength for this method is that
it's extremely fast it's good for large
data sets and it does a deep search
through extensive databases
um the weaknesses of this method are
that there's little to no validation for
the identifications
lipids are often often over annotated
meaning
someone may report the sn and double
bond position of a lipid when they may
only have data to support the fatty acyl
composition
and then you may have to sacrifice some
of that precious multi-dimensional data
that
you spent so long trying to collect such
as retention time and ccs because some
databases won't use those values
and then the search may not be sample or
species specific
and on the other hand the manual labor
is where we started when i joined the
lab and that requires that you manually
determine
all the characteristics for your little
bit of interest so
you have to find um the formula
calculate the mo for z with the adducts
you're interested in
find the fragmentation information look
at another database for the ccs value so
it can be very time consuming just to
collect
all of that information and then you
have to go dig through your data
to find those lipids and so the
strengths of this method are that you
get very confident annotations you can
utilize all that um
multi-dimensional data
and you can prioritize biologically
relevant lipids meaning those that you
expect to see in your species and sample
type or those that you're interested in
given the specific conditions you're
looking at but the weaknesses of this
method are that it's extremely time
consuming and it's not sustainable for
large data sets or deep searches
and so what we really wanted to do was
take all these strengths and create our
own method to analyze our lipid data and
so we decided that skyline was the ideal
software to do that with
when we started using skyline for our
lipid data analysis we started out with
a really simple flow um about as simple
as you can get so skyline for those who
aren't familiar with it is a targeted
data analysis software but it still
works well for untargeted data as long
as you have a list of molecules or m or
z values of interest to start with
and so our initial workflow started with
just a simple list of lipids and their m
over z values
importing and analyzing the data and
then exporting
a little bit of information
but since then
we've worked with the skyline team to
add some new small molecule capabilities
and then we've also taken advantage of a
lot of their existing features and we've
come up with a proposed workflow for
those who are interested in using
skyline for lipid analysis
where everything in yellow is new
compared to our initial workflow
and so now our target list um has lipids
that have formulas meaning we can look
at the isotope distributions we have
multiple adducts fragments even some
neutral losses our ccs values and
normalized retention times
and now when we import our data we're
filtering in multiple dimensions instead
of just by m over z
um and if we're using internal standards
we can also do some quantitation and
then we export a lot more information
and so some of the features that i'll
talk more about
in the rest of the presentation are
spectral libraries irt retention time
and drift time filtering
so what we've been doing is taking our
data from many different sample types
and developing spectral libraries in
skyline
where each lipid has information on its
m over z value its fragments
its ccs and its retention time
and so the strengths of this method are
that it is sample specific
multi-dimensional the analyses are rapid
but you can manually validate your
results
it's good for large data sets and target
lists
anyone who imports the spectral library
can prioritize the lipids that they're
interested in and can also customize the
target
list for their use
the libraries are generated from deep
searches with confident and appropriate
annotations meaning they're not over
annotated
and skyline offers straightforward
visualization and quantitation tools and
of course is vendor independent and free
and so our resulting libraries contain
hundreds of lipids from diverse classes
from these five lipid categories out of
the eight defined by lipid maps that i
mentioned earlier
and the other categories either
aren't present in the samples that we've
looked at so far or they just require
more specialized extractions
so to give you an example of what a
single library might be comprised of
here we have a sample specific library
which has over 750 features from both
positive and negative mode
and this boils down to about 500 unique
lipids when you consolidate any lipids
that have multiple adducts or that were
annotating in both ionization modes
and then when we plot this uh
library all the lipids here
by their collision cross sections and m
over z values we get these really nice
trend lines for each lipid class and so
in positive mode you can even see trends
within the trend lines and that
corresponds to
lipids that have the same total number
of carbons but varying degrees of
unsaturation
and these trend lines can really help us
validate our lipid annotations um by
verifying that we don't have any
outliers which would point to
that lipid maybe belonging to a
different class and so this can be
helpful when we're looking at those
isomers that arise from those class or
head group changes that i talked about
earlier
and then we can also compare our
experimentally determined ccs values
with those present in the ccs compendium
out of john mclean's lab at vanderbilt
um for more confidence in our
annotations and so all the ccs values
for the lipids in our current libraries
um that have a compendium match are less
than two percent different than that uh
database value which is
right where we'd want to be
so while our user workflow is really
straightforward and only requires some
manual work for validations uh we put a
lot of work into creating these
libraries so i wanted to just take a
moment to go over that process for those
who may want to create their own
libraries for a unique sample type or
maybe even a different set of molecules
so first we use the lipid creator tool
in skyline to generate transition lists
with thousands of lipids
and this is another free tool
it's actually available as a plug-in for
skyline to interface directly with the
software and i highly recommend it for
anyone who is doing lipid work
we then search for those lipids in our
data and find candidate peaks based on
their mass measurement accuracy
the coalution of adducts and the
anticipated retention times given the
lipid subclass
then we use the skyline eye mobility
predictor tool which is used to
calculate ccs values of the candidate
lipids
which we can do with our single field
calibrated data to convert any feature
drift times to ccs values
and then lipids are annotated based on
their drift timeline fragments and their
ccs values
and then for each library we create a
new irt calculator and calibrate it to
contain normalized retention times for
all the lipids that are in our library
and i'll go into some more detail on
that in a moment
and finally we create and export our
spectral libraries and we plan to
share them on skylines online data
repository panorama where anyone can
access and download them
so like i mentioned earlier we use
skyline's index retention time or irt
calculator for retention time
predictions and normalizations and so to
walk you through how we use this tool um
we start by assigning a set of about 20
reference lipids that span our lc
gradient
and then skyline will assign them a
relative irt value from 0 to 100
and so we use
endogenous lipids as our reference
points to make sure that anyone can use
it but
many people will use internal standards
for this
and so we have plans to actually create
secondary calculators for our different
libraries using the
new avanti ultimate splash 1 mix which
is a mix of
about 70 lipids from different classes
and so we can use that as a set of more
standardized reference points
and so once we calibrate the calculator
um we can add the rest of the lipids in
our library so that each one is now
assigned a unique irt value
and skyline recently added the option to
use
in addition to linear regressions either
logarithmic or lowest regressions to set
the irt values and so we've actually
found that using a lowest regression has
worked pretty well for us when we are
looking at data from
lc methods that have different gradient
times
because linear regressions just don't
always capture the differences where
some uh gradient regions may be more
compressed than others when you lower
that
time
and so both of these two steps are
something that we handle while we're
generating the library and then someone
who's using it would go in and use the
irt values to now predict the retention
times
of all the lipids in a new data set
regardless of the gradient time they're
using or any retention time shifts
so a good example of the
prediction potential of the irt
calculator is with lysolipids which are
lipids of one fatty acell chain cleaved
off and so
the sn1 and sn2 lysol lipids actually
generally do separate by lc but they
have identical fragments and then
um usually the ccs values are are too
close to distinguish them and so it's
important for us to
know which peak is for which lipid
and so here
skyline is correctly predicting that the
sn2
lysolipid alludes first
and then using that auto calculate
regression feature skyline will actually
adjust for any retention time shifts
between samples um as you can see here
with the two different predictions at
8.3 minutes versus 8.4 minutes when that
peak shifts just a little bit between
these two samples
and then we can see that the same thing
holds true for the sn1 lysolipid which
is going to be that second alluding peak
here at 8.7 or 8.8 minutes
and then in addition to predicting
predicting retention times the irt
calculator is really useful for
standardizing retention times and so
here we're looking at the retention time
of a single pe
across four different experiments and
this is in
avonte's brain total lipid extract which
is something that we use as a qc
standard in all of our lipidomics
experiments just to keep track of our
instrument performance and our lcd
performance over time
and so this first set of three
measurements was taken um here at nc
state on our current instrument and then
the rest were taken
at pnnl on a different instrument and a
couple different columns and so you can
see that this retention time can vary
pretty significantly anywhere from about
20 to close to 23 minutes
but when we convert to the irt scale
which is just an arbitrary 0 to 100
scale we can see that these values
become much more comparable and
standardized all at about 79.
so moving on from irt another feature
of our workflow is spectral library
matching where you can view the library
match just directly in that skyline
window
next to your data and you can make just
direct comparisons to see
how they match up and so here we have an
ms2 spectrum for a ceramide that we
detected in one data set
and then here's the library match
underneath
and then as you can see on the right
side of the slide these relative peak
area profiles match up pretty well so we
can be confident
in our detection of the ceramide in this
experimental data set
and then another aspect of the libraries
that i mentioned earlier is that each
lipid has a stored ccs value
which can be used for drift time
filtering if you're using iron mobility
but can easily be ignored if not
and so i mentioned that
our ccs values are calculated from drift
times using a single field calibration
and when your data file has been
calibrated and the vendor software which
we do in our agilent software
skyline can actually back calculate
drift time from ccs and so
we set a resolving power tolerance in
skyline just based on our instrument
and then skyline uses
both that ccs the calibration and then
that tolerance to determine the window
of drift times that contains the signal
that we want to extract and you can see
that with the
horizontal purple boxes here
and so in both of these examples um
these other signals would interfere with
our lipid of interest signal and
probably contribute to the extracted
intensities that we were getting so we
can
try to filter them out based on their
drift times to get a better idea of
the true abundance of the lipid that
we're actually interested in
and so this is a very important function
especially with lots of lipid isomers
and lipids that differ just by one
double bond
but i'd argue that drift time filtering
can be even more valuable when it comes
to lipid fragments especially in
negative mode
so as you can see with this pe lipid the
fragment signals for these two fatty
acyl chains 18 0 and 24
which are the teal and orange
chromatogram traces here
uh pretty much dominate the extracted
ion chromatogram um and this is due to
the fact that most of the lipids in our
sample with these two really common
fatty easel chains
will share these same fragments and our
dia method does not do any precursor
isolation when we're fragmenting
so the same fragment can be seen along
really wide ranges of our gradient
and so in some cases these fragments can
completely drown out the precursor
and this makes it difficult to annotate
lipids and can throw off the relative
intensities of our spectral library
match
but if we use drift time filtering uh we
can filter out all this excess signal
from these shared fragments
and our chromatogram looks much more
clear when only the signal that's
contributing um to our extracted
intensity
are at that correct drift time of our
little bit of interest so you can see at
the bottom here at that fatty acyl 18-0
peak
um that we obviously had another lipid
at that same retention time at a much
higher drift time that was contributing
to our fragment signal
and so one last capability that i'd like
to point out which can often get
overlooked in lipidomics is the utility
of analyzing multiple adducts for a
single lipid and so in positive mode pc
lipids form really highly abundant
protonated species um but collision
induced dissociation which is the
fragmentation
cell that we're using produces really
low neutral loss
low in abundance neutral loss fragments
and so in this example which is another
lysolipid
um any pair of peaks here could be the
correct pair if we were just looking at
the protonated species because those
fragments are so low in abundance we
wouldn't really be able to tell them
apart
but when we add in the sodium species
which is this
um brown
set of peaks we can see really clearly
see which pair of peaks is the correct
pair so adding in that second adduct
really helps us filter some of these
candidate peaks
and then another example
of where adding the sodium species can
be helpful is in assigning the fatty
acid chain composition of lipids
and so for this example lipid um which
is pretty representative of most pcs
we can barely see the neutral loss
fragments um
that would help us in the annotation of
this lipid
even though it has a very high signal
and so we wouldn't really be able to
call it a pc 18 124 because we wouldn't
be sure
of those fatty acyl chains
and so here the peak area of the
protonated precursor is an order of
magnitude greater than that of the
sodium heated species
but the sodiated species offers a lot
more fragments to help in that fatty
acyl assignment and these fragments make
up more of the total peak area with
about 10 percent as opposed to
about a quarter of a percent
and so before i wrap things up i just
wanted to give some examples of
different applications that our lab is
working on um that are using using these
libraries
so for example um i'm interested in
assessing lipid changes in various
systems following environmental
exposures
um so such as the ones on the top here
exposures to pfas or exposures to
combustion products in smoke
and so from these more environmental to
some more life sciences applications
these lipid libraries are really
facilitating a lot of the exciting
research that's happening in our lab and
hopefully in some other labs as soon as
we make them publicly available
so in the meantime if you're interested
in using skyline to process
any lipidomics or other small molecule
ion mobility data or if you just want to
learn more about creating and using
spectral libraries in skyline we worked
with the skyline team to create a
step-by-step tutorial for this type of
data analysis
it's a hands-on tutorial with some of
our fruit fly
lipid extract data
and it should be posted on the skyline
website any day now
and so to wrap up
just a few take-home points would be
that skyline allows rapid and confident
analysis of complex multi-dimensional
data which in our case is going to be lc
ims
msms
and we're working to develop some sample
specific spectral libraries containing m
over z retention time and ccs data for
hundreds of lipids
and then some of the key features of
skyline software including irt spectral
library matching and drift time
filtering
as well as seeing those adduct illusion
profiles can really allow for some
confident lipid annotations
and i'd also like to mention here that
skyline has lots of other features
outside of what i've discussed today and
they're always adding in some new
functionalities to their
software to make it useful for really
any data analysis workflow so i highly
recommend checking it out and seeing how
it can fit into your data analysis
workflow
and so with that i would like to thank
the baker lab
members our funding sources specifically
the nih molecular biotechnology training
program
and the whole team at skyline especially
those who have worked on the tools that
i talked about today or have worked on
the small molecule support
and of course thank you to the agilent
team for inviting me to speak today and
to you all for listening
and with that i'm happy to take any
questions
really for that incredible presentation
we will now begin the live q a portion
of our presentation again check out the
left side of the q a box and ask a
question so we hope you will do that we
already have some great questions coming
in
our first question what are some other
ways skyline can be incorporated into
lipidomics data analysis workflows
yeah um that's a great question and i
think um
it's important to point out that what i
was talking about in this presentation
is outside of the norm for what people
are using skyline for so
skyline like i said in the presentation
is a targeted software
um and so certainly um any targeted
lipidomics data if you're doing srm mrn
prm type methods um that is really what
skyline is built for and it's a it's a
big workforce um for for targeted data
and so that's certainly a workflow where
it's
really easily incorporated even before
you start running
any samples you can use it for your
collision energy optimization
creating methods and so
that's definitely one
place where it fits in well and then
another one would be
with validating any results that you do
get from any database searches so if
you're using a software
like lipid annotator or
lipid blast one of the ones that are
vendor neutral then you can always sort
of
rework the spreadsheet that you get at
the end there and
um
you can um
just throw that into skyline and then
just validate the
the peaks that you are seeing in the
database
thank you so much and you know what the
interferences could be on the drift time
filtering slide
yeah um
so
on that side um those data
files were collected in negative mode
and so those were both pe lipids and i
believe those interferences were one
dalton um
lower than
the lipids that we were looking at so i
would say that those were likely
sm lipids those fingo myelins because
those are sort of in that same retention
time window as the pe lipids and just
one dalton away
from the pe if they were two dots away i
would say that that would be
a loss of a double bond which is pretty
common in lipidomics analyses
thank you so much and thank you to our
audience members for these great
questions how much do you manually
validate the peak
picking in skyline kaylee
yeah that's another great question um
and i would say that i try to manually
validate um all the peaks that skyline
has picked even if it's just a really
quick run through to check that the
retention times match up and that the
um peak area profiles match up
um i think that
um
i guess i'll try to quote um will
thompson from duke he said that um the
same the same things are happening um
with any software that you're using
where you might get peaks that are
picked improperly but skyline just gives
you the opportunity to fix it and so i
definitely take advantage of that
opportunity um and fix any of the
the peak picking um
boundaries that kind of go awry
thank you so much we have time for one
more question what is your typical
lcms runtime
um so our typical
run time um we use a 38 minute gradient
which is pretty long and i'll just wrap
in another question that i see in the
chat with that um
which is that we've gone down to about
19 minutes um
and that is kind of where we'll start
losing some of the separations that we
would get and so really anywhere in that
20 to close to 40 minute range is where
we're comfortable running our lc methods
thank you kaylee for this informative
presentation would you like to provide
the audience with some closing remarks
before we go today
um i'll just say again thank you so much
to the agilent team for inviting me to
speak here today and thank you all for
for tuning in
and thank you again and as a reminder to
our audience questions we did not have
time for today and those
that are
um and those that were not
addressed during the on demand period
will be addressed
via your email you provided at the time
of registration and i want to thank our
speaker again kaylee and to everyone who
participated in the presentation we hope
you will check out the exhibit hall and
enjoy the rest of the agilent event
take care stay healthy bye bye for now